[Musique]
l'histoire la plus triste de l'année se
cache sous un toit de montmartre depuis
hier une femme digne et courageuse
maîtrise difficilement son chagrin zaza
comme on l'appelle sur la butte a décidé
d'aider la capitale a envoyé ses pigeons
à la campagne depuis dix ans tous les
pigeons de paris ne connaissait que zaza
pour sa chambre où ils allaient pondre
pouvait boire et manger elle toute seule
les aimer pour 4 millions de gens
insensible qui n'en veulent plus la
raison l'a emporté sur son coeur et elle
a ouvert sa porte à ceux dont le métier
est de prendre les pigeons pour les
mener dans de nouveaux villages de
france plus accueillant
une histoire ça fait dix ans que ça dure
alors je passe je travaillais pour eux
depuis la mise le plus personnellement
et je vais sacrifier nos vies pour cette
date là parce que pendant mineurs
pendant la guerre de 1914 j'en ai eu un
soleil au fort de vous re qui a sauvé un
et cousins et pour moi c'est bête de
course à pied ils ont rendu beaucoup de
services qui soient voyageurs aux
gouttières et je trouve que ce sont des
soldats plus comme les appelait dans
nord dans mon pays et on ne doit pas les
tortures à tous les coins de rue comme
je les ai vus sortir et des années je
les ai vus crucifié et qu'est-ce qui me
pouvoir ce sont ce qu'ils sont cons a
rendu à veulent passer sa perte est ce
la porte köhler the pente conor j
appréhendais il pouvait plus voler les
étapes suivantes moselle tichon vous
consacrer toute votre vie aux pigeons
oui elle depuis dix ans que ça toute ma
vie pour eux qu'est ce que vous faites
pour tous les jours je fais des menaces
tous les jours pour eux je fais des
travaux très dur pour eux
je travaille durement faut arriver et si
c'est leur fils chez moi parce qu'ici ce
que quartier personne est vital ils
viennent manger dans macha ici c'est le
refuge divers y viennent se chauffer
parce que personne la vitale dans le
toit ici personne ordonne à manger et
tous les jours entre 1h et 1h30 oui ils
viennent doivent être changées le matin
à 5 heures du matin quand ils font
manger ils font leurs the oc je crois
oui lors chez moi que je détruis au
fusil et l'or aujourd'hui vous avez
décidé de dd la préfecture de la seine
vie et je remercie beaucoup de préfet de
paris je lui demande moins graves
bienfaitrice des pigeons qui la ramasse
tous accusent qui pourra parce que au
coin des rues ce sont tous des
malheureux et des martyrs que moi j'ai
vu torturés je crois que vous avez parmi
tous les pigeons de paris un pigeon dit
que vous préférez comment sont fins et
là où il est il est dehors il est
parvenu aujourd'hui il n'est pas parmi
moi aujourd'hui la somme qu'il a été
trompé son petit état seront pied et là
vous l'avez regardé combien de temps
cela comme aux as où il est il vient
donc en bonne hausse il était tombé du
nid il a 7 1 7 1 et l'argent que vous
leur donniez en leur achetant la
nourriture allez-vous faire de cet
argent maintenant
de sages à la maintenant que je leur
donne et je n'ai ni la folie des
grandeurs ni les toilettes je ferai du
bien at-il malheureux je tâcherai de
faire du bien et prenez pas aux
orphelins d'assistance publique et je
ferai du bien aux petits frères
d'auteuil ou vieillards est ce que vous
aimez d'autres bêtes que les pigeons
madame et j'aime beaucoup les chevaux
parce que ce sont deux bêtes de guerre
monsieur le chien le pigeon et le cheval
se sont trop bêtes sa crypte home
edition aussi principalement je les aime
beaucoup et j'aime j'aime tout le monde
et j'aime tout ce qui est bon sur la
terre alors l'argent que je dépense et
pour toutes ces bêtes là maintenant
qu'ils vont partir je suis très
émotionnel c'est un peu votre vie qui
s'en va madame
non
madame
c'est tout
[Musique]